Seeing dead people, becoming a neuroscientist,
and foiling burglars can be exhausting -
turns out some child stars just need a break!
Anna Chlumsky won America's hearts when she
starred as Vada Sultenfuss in the 1991 film "My
Girl," only her second project after a tiny part
in 1989's "Uncle Buck." Chlumsky followed that up
with a less successful but still charming sequel
"My Girl 2" and similar roles in "Trading Mom"
and "Gold Diggers: The Secret of Bear Mountain."
Things started to dry up for Chlumsky around 1997,
and she stopped acting entirely
in 1998 when she went to college,
telling People magazine in February 2022 -
"As a kid, you're just along for the
ride, but it can be extremely damaging.
[In college] I had this out-of-body moment where
I realized, 'I don't have to do this anymore.'"
"I don't have to FEEL like this anymore. Like,
I don't have to feel like I won't book
something, like I'm not good enough."
After graduating from the University of
Chicago, Chlumsky told People that she
did not immediately return to acting, finding
entry-level journalism jobs, but eventually
enrolled in acting school. She returned
to the business with a short film in 2005,
but hit it big in 2012 when she scored a main
role in HBO's political comedy "Veep." Chlumsky
received six Primetime Emmy Award nominations
for playing Amy Brookheimer in the show,
and it remains the highlight of her career.
She has since starred in the Netflix miniseries
"Inventing Anna," and can most recently be
seen in Peacock's original film, "They/Them."
As far as child stars go, Mayim Bialik has always
seemed to have her head screwed on straight.
She began in show business before she even hit
her teens, appearing in TV series like "Webster"
and "Molloy" before becoming super famous as the
titular character in the sitcom "Blossom," which
aired from 1990 to 1995. Despite her success as a
kid actor, Bialik expressed mixed feelings about
children acting professionally. In a post for her
website Grok Nation, Bialik discussed how she sees
theater as valuable for kids, but how
performing on cue can take an emotional toll.
Bialik largely stopped acting for a decade, from
1995 to 2005, except for some voice work and two
or three small guest spots in low-profile shows
like "Welcome to Paradox." She had a memorable
three-episode stint on "Curb Your Enthusiasm" in
2005 and played a doctor in 10 episodes of "The
Secret Life of the American Teenager," but it was
Bialik's casting as Amy Farrah Fowler in "The Big
Bang Theory" that completely altered her career.
She joined the show in 2010, appeared in more than
200 episodes, and received four Primetime Emmy
Award nominations in addition to other awards.
She currently has her own sitcom, "Call Me
Kat," and hosts "Jeopardy" in her spare time.
Perhaps most impressively, Bialik used her time
away from Hollywood to earn multiple degrees,
including a doctorate in neuroscience
that she completed in 2007 at UCLA.
When it comes to child actors, Macauley Culkin is
arguably one of the most famous there ever was.
Culkin was just five years old when he made his
first uncredited appearance in a film but became
massively famous at age 10 with his iconic
role as Kevin McCallister in the 1990 film
"Home Alone." Over the next handful of years, he
racked up many credits, starring in films such as
"My Girl," "The Good Son," and "The Pagemaster."
After appearing as the title character in the
"Richie Rich" film in 1994, Culkin stepped
away from acting for nearly a full decade.
Culkin "retired" from acting in his early teens
because he no longer wanted to do it, but also
because it allowed him to stop bankrolling
his parents. He became emancipated at age 14
and has said his father was abusive. As he told
comedian Marc Maron on his "WTF" podcast in 2018,
"I had been wanting to take a break for a while
and eventually I was like, 'I'm done guys,
hope you all made your money because
there is no more coming from me.'"
"You guys give up, or ya thirsty for more?"
Culkin returned to the screen on his
own terms in 2003, with an acclaimed
role in the film "Party Monster." He has
since had memorable parts in movies like
"Saved!" and in television series
such as "American Horror Story."
Given how successful Macauley Culkin was as a
child, many people forget that his siblings Rory
and Kieran both acted as children as well. Kieran,
in particular, has been able to achieve tremendous
success as an adult after a time away from the
limelight. Kieran, the eldest by two years,
began his acting career with a small part in "Home
Alone," after which he worked steadily in films
like "Father of the Bride," "Only the Lonely,"
and "Nowhere to Run." He notched more than a
dozen screen credits by the time he turned 18 in
2000 and, two years later, established himself
with an acclaimed role in "Igby Goes Down," for
which he was nominated a Golden Globe Award.
After "Igby," Kieran did not appear
on screen for six years — though he
did have a few stage roles during that
time, telling The Hollywood Reporter -
"I would not have been able to
handle whatever kind of success
or attention came from that. So I
quite literally ran away from it."
Culkin returned to acting full-time in 2008,
and his career hit new heights in 2018,
when he originated the role of Roman Roy on
the successful HBO show "Succession." For
his work on the series thus far, Culkin has
been nominated for one Primetime Emmy Award,
three Golden Globe Awards, and one
individual Screen Actors Guild Award.
She is nearly 60 now, so younger generations
probably do not know how big of a star Brooke
Shields was back when she was young. According
to Women's Wear Daily, Shields was less than
a year old when she got her start in modeling
and she continued to model throughout her early
life. Shields was famously part of a provocative
campaign for Calvin Klein Jeans as a teenager,
is the youngest person ever to land on the cover
of Vogue, and her eyebrows alone have inspired
many a beauty article. But Shields is not just
known as a model, and her acting career began
similarly early. She controversially played a
child sex worker in the 1978 film "Pretty Baby,"
and as a teen, appeared in fare like "The
Blue Lagoon," "Endless Love," and "Sahara."
After professionally working
for literally her entire life,
Shields took some time off between 1984
and 1988 to attend Princeton University,
from which she graduated with honors, according
to The Chicago Tribune. She re-entered Hollywood
upon her graduation and, in 1996, landed her
biggest role to date, the lead in the sitcom
"Suddenly Susan," which aired for four
seasons and earned Shields two Golden
Globe Award nominations. Shields has continued to
work steadily in the years since her sitcom ended,
appearing mostly in television in shows like
"Lipstick Jungle," and "Jane the Virgin."
The list of children who have been nominated
for Oscars is short, so Haley Joel Osment's
2000 Academy Award nod for his work in "The Sixth
Sense" is significant. Osment was 11 years old
at the time of his nomination, and he remains
one of the youngest nominees of all time. The
actor had already been in show business for half a
decade, starting with commercials and very quickly
transitioning to film. One of his first parts
was playing Forrest's son in "Forrest Gump," and
he also had main roles on the television series
"Thunder Alley" and "The Jeff Foxworthy Show."
Osment had nearly two dozen acting credits
before "The Sixth Sense," but that's the
role that took him to the next level. After his
Oscar nom, Osment had high-profile leading roles
in films such as "Pay It Forward" and "A.I.
Artificial Intelligence." He never officially
retired from acting, but Osment took on mostly
voice work between the years of 2005 and 2012.
"It's cold! Donald, gimme a coat!"
Though he got into a bit of trouble with a DUI
at age 18, Osment got things back on track and
graduated from New York University during his
acting hiatus. He started appearing on-camera
again in 2013, starting with the television series
"Alpha House," and has established himself well as
an adult thespian with roles in television series
such as "Future Man" and "The Kominsky Method."
Andrea Barber started her career in 1982,
at age six, when she began appearing as
Carrie Brady on the soap opera "Days of Our
Lives." She remained on "Days" until 1986,
during which time she also did guest stints on
other television series. Her true claim to fame,
however, is her scene-stealing role as D.J.
Tanner's best friend and neighbor Kimmy
Gibbler on the iconic sitcom "Full House." Barber
appeared in 146 episodes of the show between 1987
and 1995 — and then left the entertainment
business. As she told E! News in 2020 -
"I know a lot of people who play
outlandish characters like this do
struggle with typecasting or just being
seen as that. I never struggled. I left
the business at 18 just because
my heart wasn't in acting anymore"
Thankfully for us "Full House" fans, Barber
was willing to return to the role that made her
famous when Netflix launched a spinoff, "Fuller
House," in 2016. The show ran for five seasons,
but Barber may stick with acting
this time, telling E! News -
"I've got the bug now. I would
love to continue if it's still
doing comedy because I think that's
my sweet spot and I love it so much."
Barber has since appeared in guest roles on
two series, "Minutiae" and "That Girl Lay Lay."
Twins have always been really popular amongst
child actors, particularly babies and toddlers,
as labor laws limit the amount of time very young
children can spend on a set. Along with the Olsen
twins and the Mowry twins, the Sprouse twins are
up there in terms of fame. But while both Dylan
and Cole Sprouse worked as child actors, only Cole
has come back to acting full time since they both
took a hiatus to attend college. Even then, he
once told Teen Vogue that he almost quit for good.
The Sprouses made their acting
debut before he was even a year old,
when he started appearing as Patrick
Kelly in the sitcom "Grace Under Fire."
He and his brother shared this role, much
like they did with other big gigs like playing
Ross's son Ben on "Friends" and Adam Sandler's
adopted son Julian in the comedy "Big Daddy."
"But I did most scenes."
"No I did."
"No I did! Mommy says I did."
"Did he?"
To kids of their generation, the Sprouse brothers
are perhaps best known as Zack and Cody Martin,
mischievous twin brothers featured on the Disney
program "The Suite Life of Zack and Cody" and its
spinoff "The Suite Life on Deck." Cole Sprouse
did not act between 2011 and 2017, mostly to
attend New York University and study archeology.
He is now more famous than ever, due to his role
as Jughead Jones on The CW's "Riverdale," which
was recently renewed for its seventh season.
Diane Lane has been a Hollywood heavyweight
for decades. The actor started her screen
with roles in films such as "Ladies and
Gentleman, the Fabulous Stains," "The
Outsiders," and "Rumble Fish," before deciding
to step away from acting at the age of 19.
According to Hello magazine, Lane moved to
Georgia during her hiatus from Hollywood.
While some sources, like The
Herald, have suggested Lane
retired because "The Cotton Club" was
a flop, others have said it had more
to do with rebuilding her relationship with
her mother, telling the Los Angeles Times -
"I hadn't been close to my mom for a long
time, so we had a lot of homework to do.
We had to repair our relationship
because I wanted my mother back."
Two years after her 1987 return to acting,
she received a Primetime Emmy nomination for
her work in the miniseries "Lonesome Dove."
She has since been nominated for many awards,
including an Oscar for her role in the
film "Unfaithful." Other standout projects
include "A Walk on the Moon," "Trumbo," and
playing Superman's Earth mom, Martha Kent,
in "Man of Steel" and "Batman
v Superman: Dawn of Justice."
Gaby Hoffman has lived an unconventional life.
The popular child star grew up in Manhattan's
Chelsea Hotel, and according to The
Guardian, she started acting at age
four to help pay the family's bills. Her
movie debut was in 1989's "Field of Dreams,"
after which she starred with Hollywood giants
in films like "Sleepless in Seattle" and "Uncle
Buck." She was also successful as a teenager, with
performances in "Now and Then," "Everyone Says I
Love You," and "200 Cigarettes." Hoffmann
continued appearing in films until 2001,
at which point she decided to step
away from the screen, telling NPR -
"I always was planning on giving it up. I never
set out to be an actor. I always knew, since I
was seven or eight years old, that it was a means
to an end and that I wanted to go to college."
After attending Bard College,
Hoffmann was on the fence about acting again, but
eventually decided to try things out as an adult.
"I saw 'The Maid' at Sundance —"
"Oh yeah."
"— And I was like, 'Okay, if people
are making movies like this still,
anywhere in the world, I
wanna keep making movies.'"
A decade later, she found major success with
a recurring role in the TV series "Girls,"
receiving one Primetime Emmy nomination,
and a main role on Amazon's "Transparent,"
receiving two nominations. Hoffmann has also
done some amazing work in smaller films,
such as "Obvious Child" and other high
profile series, like "Winning Time."
Alicia Goranson is mostly known for playing the
original Becky Conner on the sitcom "Roseanne,"
which she started doing in 1988 at age 13.
She remained with the show for five seasons,
eventually leaving to attend Vassar College. In
addition to "Roseanne," Goranson appeared in "How
to Make an American Quilt," but she was not as
prolific as some other child stars of her era.
After leaving "Roseanne" in 1992,
Goranson appeared on the show a few
more times through 1996, but did not act
again until 1999, telling Parade in 2019 -
"I really missed just having a regular
life. I craved being in a real classroom
and not just a studio schoolroom and having
the opportunity to be around my peers."
Goranson returned to the business with
a juicy role in the heartbreaking film
"Boys Don't Cry," but disappeared again until
she popped up with a guest spot on a 2004 episode
of "Sex and the City." She continued to work,
but mostly in small guest roles that received
little notice. In 2018, Goranson returned
to prominence when "Roseanne" was rebooted.
After the real-life Roseanne was fired, the
show was renamed "The Conners" in an attempt
to refocus on the rest of the family but
preserve what worked. ABC has renewed "The
Conners" for Season 5, and Goranson's Becky
remains a big part of the spinoff's focus.
Thora Birch is now approaching middle age,
but if you remember her as a youngster,
you are not alone. Birch took on her first film
role at the tender age of six, when she appeared
in "Purple People Eater." She then went on to film
multiple television shows, including "Day by Day"
and "Parenthood," but really established herself
as a child star with her film work. Her early
films include the Halloween classic "Hocus Pocus,"
coming-of-age drama "Now and Then," and the comedy
"Monkey Trouble." She continued acting throughout
her teenage years and garnered much acclaim with
roles in critical faves like "American Beauty" and
"Ghost World." Then the actor somewhat vanished.
After acting sporadically between 2006 and 2017,
Birch appeared to have stopped acting entirely
from 2012 to 2016. This is not surprising,
given that the actor's father was notoriously
heavy-handed. According to the New York Times,
Jack Birch was allegedly intrusive on
sets, even after his daughter reached
adulthood. He was apparently on set when
his daughter filmed a sex scene in 2007,
at age 25, and even got her fired from a play
in 2010 when he threatened one of her co-stars.
Given her innate talent, Birch has thankfully
returned to acting in recent years. She dipped
her toe back in with recurring parts on shows like
"The Walking Dead," and smaller film roles like
the disaster movie '13 Minutes' and has a main
role in the upcoming Netflix series, "Wednesday."
As the daughter of a famous singer, it's not
surprising that actor Mackenzie Phillips, like
her younger half-siblings Bijou and Chynna, ended
up in the entertainment business. Mackenzie's'
early start in the industry led to a life filled
with struggle, including much-publicized addiction
issues and an incestuous relationship with her
own father which she discussed in her book,
"High on Arrival". Fortunately, Phillips found
stability and happiness in her later years,
and she is now working as a counselor for
others struggling with substance addiction.
"I think that people understand that I
- that I've been there, and that clients
believe me when I say there's a way out."
Phillips began her acting career in
1973 with a small role in a TV film,
"Doris," and a part in the classic "American
Graffiti." She rose to prominence a couple of
years later as rebellious teenager Julie Cooper
on "One Day at a Time," which remains her most
significant role to date. Phillips was 25 by
the end of the nine-season run, and she left
acting for music a year later in 1986. It was not
until 1994 that she returned to the screen, mostly
for guest spots on shows like "Melrose Place"
and "Caroline in the City." In 1999, Phillips
finally found another memorable part, playing a
rocker mom in the Disney show "So Weird." She has
also had noteworthy roles on "Orange Is The New
Black" and the "One Day at a Time" reboot series.
If you or anyone you know has been a victim of
sexual assault, help is available. Visit the Rape,
Abuse & Incest National Network website or contact
RAINN's National Helpline at 1-800-656-HOPE
1-800-656 or (4673).